after uh just a couple of days after  magnus won the the world championship  match in dubai uh he said um  he was in doubt whether or not he will  play another world championship match  and i believe yesterday he told a  norwegian newspaper he said i will not  play another match what are your  thoughts on this is he bluffing or do  you actually  i think i think  he's doing that thing  where um to raise the price and i've  done it also a lot um well not in this  matter unfortunately i can't play that  game but  whenever you negotiate  and you try to raise your price the only  way to do that is to be ready to walk  away  i think he's ready to walk away  like fisher did right yeah i think i  think i think he is really ready to walk  away  but but he'll be also happy to take uh a  good offer okay  so it's all about the bid thank you too  much